[Music]
yeah walk back to South Africa but I get
it
[Applause]
Casey asked me to make some sort of a
kick-ass intro freeze tech Tuesday
segments but I completely forgot today's
today and what should we reviewed this
week for tech review Tuesday little mini
segues that go under each foot tech
review Tuesday for tech review Tuesday
tech review Tuesday the eat shoot a
proper intro yet protective a toothy hey
did you finish the tech Tuesday and so
there's no excuse not to finish tech
Tuesday tech Tuesday finish it already
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah where's the tech Tuesday from rush
Tuesday tech Tuesday
where's the tech Tuesday in fro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Tuesday
tip Tuesday I couldn't finish it Tuesday
see sounds tip Tuesday I couldn't finish
it Tuesday Tuesday
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching seeing sounds I hope
this is I hope that we we made this
instead of making a intro to tech
Tuesday thank you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]